AUDIENCE: That was awesome,
but my card was stolen.
[LAUGHING]
GUEST SPEAKER 1: So this is the
Soil Moisture Inversion Level
Estimator, or SMILE,
for short, and it
will keep your plants happy.
GUEST SPEAKER 2: By telling you
when your soil is too wet, too
dry, or just right.
So it uses an RGB LED, and
any soil moisture sensor.
GUEST SPEAKER 1: And
here's how it works,
GUEST SPEAKER 2: So just water
turns blue, and that's too wet.
GUEST SPEAKER 1: It says "Gone
Fishing" in the silly monitor.
[LAUGHING]
GUEST SPEAKER 2: Moist
soil will turn green
if you stick it in all the way.
And then it says--
what does it say?
GUEST SPEAKER 2: I feel good.
GUEST SPEAKER 2: I
feel good, so you
don't need to water your plant.
And then completely dry
soil is red, and it says--
GUEST SPEAKER 1: I'm thirsty.
GUEST SPEAKER 2:
Water me, I'm thirsty.